welcome back to the real rejects i'm
greg alba i'm john humphrey we're going
to watch spider-man 3
mysterio return confirmed sinister six
spider-verse explain from our buddies
over at new rock stars
let's just swing into action look at
that
okay let's go
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and spider-man 3 has been giving us
more and more clues pointing to this
movie's mysterious
plot i'm talking mysterio himself
confirmed two factor into this story and
there's
actual evidence this time that we can
all look at instead of us having to take
the word of some
scooper with his inside sources aka
whatever we'll get the fans most height
hey back off of daniel rpk
mikey sudden and cosmic wondering
everything always
spoiler warning sources are never wrong
spider-man have come all kinds of new
looks tom holland is peter parker on a
snowy new york street the movie is
confirmed to be asian oh there is
footage
there's actual moving footage jay's
working in a bakery peter pan donut and
pastry shop
that is a high def image decor in the
windows but in a closer later angle
mj has put up some hanukkah at once too
but the crucial details were spotted on
a poster wall plastered with missing
persons flyers
and then these two peculiar finds an
image of mysterio with
uh and then further down in the corner
citizens to defend spidey so there's a
lot to unpack here first this confirms
our theory from spider-man apart from
home that whether or not mysterio
quentin beg the man
is dead something by the way that
remains very much up for debate since
peter failed to work his question to
edith
mysterio is bigger than one man people
it's a whole
team of disaffected stark employees and
community theater actors
working collectively to pull off these
illusions i want to just pause super
quick to say that i of course believe
mysterio is real
for him to have altered that footage
that was on display
in the mid-credits scene of spider-man
far from home
that sequence would have had to have
occurred first for him to later on have
manipulated it it's the only way it
makes sense let's proceed
as we saw when mysterio's footage was
downloaded to a flash drive and then
later in the post-credits scene
mysterio's doctored footage framed
exactly the team of mysterio lives on
fully capable of ruining peter parker's
life
or it could have been the team that just
manipulated it for him
a deadly trickle of fake news propaganda
and that
is what we are now seeing with this
mysterio poster the rise of conspiracy
theories in the mcu
people making mysterio into a kind of
martyr and it's not just the helmet
stage of the character this is gonna be
a big deal because another poster
shows the face of jake gyllenhaal and
while that still doesn't mean he'll
physically appear in the film
it does confirm that they care enough
about this subplot to at least pay
gyllenhaal some appearance fee and to
credit him in the movie which they have
to do if they use someone's likeness
this is also consistent with clues we
spotted in orbeez
which while less of an mcu property and
more of a sponsee one
it is expected to be loosely connected
to the mcu spider-man with a crossover
from michael keaton adrian toombs and
background graffiti labeling spider-man
murderer sony did delay morbius but only
to october
signaling that they still really need
this movie to come out before spider-man
3 in december
now of course spider-man isn't a
complete public enemy there's this whole
other campaign
citizens to defend spidey it's a much
nerdier name i'm guessing a small
operation headed up by like ned or mj or
flash
we do know he's a big spidey fanboy to
be honest i'm a bit more he's at least a
member
missing posters feels like something you
would see right after the snap
not on the other side of the blip once
the avengers brought everyone back
what is causing all these people
children are missing
for the children the one division tie-in
oh
dang oh that i mean they've been saying
this will tie into one division and
doctor strange that's actually perfect
holy sh ah doing it for the children
okay this is the restless
missing a new killer on the loose in
manhattan or
some multiverse crisis causing
individuals to disappear from this
reality
and others from alternate realities to
suddenly appear in this one in fact if
such a crisis
is gripping new york in this whole world
that could explain
why the public is embracing mysterio who
claimed to be a warrior from another
dimension within the multiverse
in their eyes an avenger type hero who
really could have helped them in such an
event
mysterio was totally lying there kevin
feige has suggested peter's excitement
for the idea of the multiverse from this
scene
and the idea that doctor strange is
going to be in this movie according to
feige those two things are going to tell
us a lot about where this movie is going
and now with mysterio we are starting to
get a much clearer picture of what is
going on
so how does this mystery would say the
one division
i think that would be a lot more fun
well we know that doctor strange will
join the plot along with alfred molina
doc och and
jamie fox electro last seen in totally
alternate universe spider-man films
meanwhile
everyone from tobey maguire andrew
garfield willem dafoe kirsten dunst emma
stone to charlie cox matt murdock
daredevil from the netflix series
have been rumored to appear by various
scoopers with varying degrees of
reliability but none of these have
been confirmed big we'll see on the rest
of those
either way it is clear sony i think he
has issues with scoopers
i was gonna say yeah i wonder how he
feels come on eric you're
awesome you're all about theories and
breakdowns come on man let the scoopers
have the scooping
every scoop is a theory based on an
easter egg
come on come on
granted your theories are more based in
actual evidence
knowledge of the source goal is to
bridge this
mcu spider-man with elements from past
films and alternate universe within the
spider-man brand
to create a kind of live-action
spider-verse these mysterio posters set
the stage for that conflict following
far from home peter parker continues to
face scrutiny from team mysterio
who might have pre-recorded several
contingency tapes designed to ruin
spider-man's reputation
in the event they failed in europe the
thing is this detached
leaderless crew of special effects
experts would struggle to maintain an
effective media campaign without
help some of that help could come from
jay jonah jameson's daily bugle site but
i think they would need bigger backing
return public opinion against an avenger
so i think it is possible that team
mysterio is being backed by
oscorp
[Music]
eager to have gotten their hands on the
late tony stark's edith tech and their
whole satellite-linked drone fleet
if those defoe rumors are true that
could be how we get norman osborne as a
corporate villain and maybe a silent
part
i just want to stop and say i believe
you that would be
yeah i believe you i think this is 100
true
plus theory this is around the time i'd
expect ozcorp or harry osborne
to come into uh the spider-man films
either part three or part four so i
think
that maybe not even harry osborne but
yeah you're bringing up willing to foe
already
yeah getting the back like it all just
sounds so damn solid
and especially with like laying roots
for sinister sticks and stuff like that
like having oz corp yeah is like the
first harbinger of like the real
possibility of that coming to fruition
oh and i love all the media propaganda
and how that's causing a divide
amongst the citizens of the world to
split between mysterio and spider-man
who to believe who not to believe
which is nothing like real life yeah not
their leaving
keep politics out of my spider-man movie
or to this assault on spider-man's
public image and when the media campaign
doesn't work
norman osborne might decide to escalate
to an actual team of people to take
spidey down
and that's how we get the assembly of
the sinister six vulture electro doc ock
maybe morbius or scorpion or carnage or
team
mysterio all over seen by norman osborne
green goblin
now here are where things get a bit
tricky because on one hand the inclusion
of all universe actors like alfred
molina and jamie foxx
might suggest that these villains
origins could be from a kind of
multiverse crossover of villains they
pop in through some kind of multiverse
collision
or through a portal of some kind but on
the other hand we have heard it
suggested that sony might make these
villains
not the same exact forms that they were
in those past movies
but like a different doc a different
electro
guys that have just always existed in
the mcu just
played by the same actors for some
reason that muddy
approach is kind of what they did with
jk simmons j jonah jameson yeah
hey look it's the saint j jonah don't
that nostalgia feel great
uh but wasn't his peter parker tobey
maguire
yeah exactly this don't have to make
sense pretty solid amy pascal impression
whether these citizens
you see that's the problem with it is
the muddy approach i think
is like this muddy approach i think is
okay if
the fact that let's say tokyo and andrew
garfield happen to not be in this movie
even though
it's not 100 confirmed it feels like
it's pretty much there
yeah let's say they're not in the movie
then that approach is fine
actually i think if they if they are
already from
like they're just reprising the roles
and they're just playing different
versions of them right
yeah but if toby maguire and andrew
garfield are in here
it would only make sense to be tied to
their respective
franchise villains yeah like i think it
would have to be that case
yeah and i'd prefer it to be that it
would be more exciting
then you'd have to go through some hoops
and explanations to be like yeah alfred
molina survived
willem dafoe survived even though like
the whole thing with harry osborne and
that trilogy was all about
you know the death of his father and
wanting to get revenge and spider
there's a lot you got to unpack
at the same time though i think that
toby mcguire and andrew garfield are for
sure
indeed in this movie they would have to
be from
their franchises or six villains are
given multiversal origins in the film
or if sony shrugs it off as if it just
makes sense for them to have already
been
in this reality as these actors i think
dr
strange in this movie represents marvel
studios in kevin feige's solution to
that madness
and within the movie peter parker's
solution to the sinister six crisis
because the best way for peter to face
so many villains
is for him to team up with doctor
strange to navigate the multiverse to
find allies
other spider-man alternate universes yes
how they could get toby and andrew
yeah exactly by doctor strange's role in
the story because what are they just
bringing him in so he can do the winds
of watum
no he's in there because he knows his
way around the multiverse so the
sinister six backed by norman osborne
versus
team spidey backed by the sorcerer
supreme i mean even sony couldn't ruin
that
i am wearing our new latest obsession
shirt an unusual couple
it's amazing and it has secret easter
eggs revealed via
augmented reality you can get my shirt
at your swords.com
follow me on instagram eavoss follow new
rockstars and subscribe for breakdowns
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
cool stuff man cool stuff i love this
one yeah that's so fun
i appreciate all the hard work you do
eric everything is
presented from not scoops alone
you gotta say it though sometimes you do
talk about some scoops as well though
you know sometimes it is a scoop
sometimes a scoop has a little bit of
some
scoopies they're very enticing
it seemed like you had a little bit of a
shift in tone there
when it came to certain scoops i'd say
your
ease of voice in these videos let us
just be distracted from them don't worry
you're still sent by to us you're still
the king of them all
right so john and i you're still the
king absolutely but yeah everything
we're getting from these leaked photos i
i wait for these videos specifically
just to do reactions to them for you
guys so
yeah i wasn't aware of these mysterio
photos
but i mean i think mysterio's alive i'd
be very surprised if he isn't
and i i do like what they were hinting
at you got
the current world of with those photos
alone
that some people are on spider-man's
side some people are on mysterio side
they're using media propaganda to sort
of push it but then they have that
mystery clue of those of the people
missing
which i feel like can tie into the
events of one division
and considering the fact that wanda
vision is building its series off of a
great mystery surrounding it i think
it's pretty cool that spider-man will do
that
not just in the marketing i i don't
often associate the mcu films with
being about mystery and i think that
this spider-man movie will probably have
a lot of that ingredient a mystery
imbued in here so there were actually
quite a bit to take
just from those those posters they're
very like lived in photos
yeah and then those ending shots of
spider-man on christmas or the holiday
ending finale
just in time this is gonna be like
scrooge he's gonna be visited by the
ghosts of spiderman cast
and then he's gonna have a whole
reclamation of his own soul that way
i'm very excited for this this is gonna
be a really cool movie i can't wait for
the
like we're definitely gonna get a
trailer at some point this year
um can't wait can't wait thank you new
rockstars thank you to all for watching
subscribe click that notification bell
any big exciting spider-man things come
up of course we're going to talk about
it at some point
uh within a couple days span last but
not least
scuba steve i thought of you immediately
as this video
started because of the crazy designs on
display and i mean you
obviously have talked about your
graffiti art on this channel but you're
a guy of various interests
and i don't know i mean i don't want to
push you into a profession
you don't want to be in but i feel like
you could do some crazy
set design work or crazy work kind of
like this for movies and stuff you know
take your unique style and then blend it
in with some of these popular characters
and stuff i don't know this made me
think of youtube because of new yorkers
uh but yeah matt i hope you're doing
well i know that it has been a very very
up and down time especially in the line
of work that you're now
in uh but i just want to send you some
love and i hope you're doing well today
happy new year buddy hope you're doing
[Music]
well